Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
thor love and thunder video about how marvel is
going to explain thor's hammer in the movie
there's been a lot of new teasers that have
been dropping there's been a lot of questions
because thor is still wielding stormbreaker and
he's still worthy in the movie but they also have
a version of his original hammer even though the
movie is going to be way crazier than you expect
than thor ragnarok was they're gonna have a lot of
deep cuts from the mythology also explain what's
going on with the trailer because everyone wants
to know what's going on with the thor love and
thunder trailer so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos because
that trailer is coming soon and we will do as much
zooming and enhancing as you could possibly do
real quick shout out to my friends at raid shadow
of legends who asked to sponsor this video raid
shadow legends is one of the biggest mobile games
in the world right now that's totally free to play
that's right it's free they wanted me to tell you
about their epic champions they have this month
like ursula the mourner of the bannerlords and the
royal guard of the high elves ursula can revive
your whole team and makes them tough as bricks
buffing their strength and defense and her aura
gives you plus 24 speed in the doom tower royal
guard is mostly a pve player which is what i
spend most of my time doing story based play
pve play some of his really useful abilities are
attacks that scale damage against your enemies max
hp he also decreases enemy defense and he's got a
random proc ability that can reduce their number
of turns potentially and that's just a fraction
of stuff they're introducing this month because
this month is raid's three-year anniversary
and the celebrations are going to be huge
raids introducing its first ever champion skins
skins let you alter a champion's appearance to
something that suits your style your preference
my favorite new skins so far are the ones for
the arbiter this is the best time to get started
in raid and if you use my link in the description
below or scan the qr code right here that i'll
put on screen in the video new players will get
a free starter pack worth almost 40 dollars to
kickstart your game we're talking free champions
misericord tiger soul romero 10 magic xp brew
10 force xp brew and 10 spirit xp brew all that
free stuff they give you you can find in your
inbox in the upper right hand corner right here
so be sure to check it out so marvel was pretty
clear that they were adapting both the mighty
thor and the gore of the god butcher story lines
for thor love and thunder most of you have read
versions of those comic stories or you've seen
my previous videos on the movie christian bale
was probably one of the biggest surprises he's
playing their gore the god butcher he's going to
wreck in this movie and he goes on a mission
to kill all the legit gods of the mcu we're
getting the tutorial on how legit gods in the mcu
work during the moon knight episodes right now
i've been doing videos for all those episodes
so i'll link them in the description below but
i've also started to explain the difference
between just really powerful cosmic beings
and legit gods because technically the mcu
gods are really powerful cosmic beings but just
because you're a cosmic being doesn't mean that
you're automatically a god best example of that
is the celestials the celestials are probably
one of the most powerful cosmic beings that
we've ever seen in the mcu but they themselves
are not gods and even though thor is getting
brand new armor he's got his helmet on from the
comics this is what his new costume looks like
it looks like they're almost trying to take into a
full-on version of roon king thor from the comics
which would be awesome he still won't be quite as
powerful as the celestials so just because you're
a legit mcu god doesn't automatically make you
as powerful as the most powerful cosmic beings
so thor love and thunder is like the crash
course in mcu guys we're gonna see a bunch
of the different gods from different cultures
around the universe as gore goes on his mission
my early theory also before he winds up going face
to face with real thor is that he's going to wind
up killing fake thor fake loki and maybe even
fake hello too because they are doing another
one of those funny fake plays in the movie this
time it's parodying the events of thor ragnarok
matt damon is in the movie playing an asgardian
who plays a version of loki this thor is actually
chris hemsworth's real brother luke hemsworth
most of you will recognize him from westworld
in legit their new fake hella is actually going to
be played by melissa mccarthy which is another big
surprise so i think they're performing the play
and then eventually gord the godbutcher will show
up thor is not there and he'll wind up killing all
the fake versions because he's currently off with
the guardians of the galaxy in space getting super
swole with star lore's bowflex because the events
of the movie are taking place after spider-man
no way home there was an easter egg for it during
spider-man no way home they said that there was
political strife happening in new asgard that
was just a reference to people being upset with
all the changes that valkyrie was making as the
new king we've seen the loki series with the
version of kang all the timelines going crazy
the kang multiverse war and we'll have already
seen the events of doctor strange multiverse
of madness when this comes out multiverse is
like the operative trope in marvel phase four
other universes other dimensions with a bunch
of variants of all the big characters we've seen
before thank you very much for coming back patrick
stewart in bringing those fox x-men variants with
you maybe some fox fantastic four characters too
so early on when people learned about the movie
because all this multiverse stuff is happening now
people thought the multiverse would be the reason
that they explained this alternate version of jane
foster thor in this version of thor's hammer but
that is not the case it's actually way way simpler
than that there might actually be some multiverse
stuff going on during the movie there might still
be some variants somewhere in there still holding
out hope for a real version of loki showing up
at some point from the multiverse even though
tom hiddleston said that he was not supposed to be
in the movie but the way they're explaining thor's
hammer during the movie is that odin's original
enchantment is going to still be more powerful
than hella just physically smashing the original
hammer to pieces and the reason why it's mcu jane
foster like the one we've been seeing this whole
time who becomes a version of thor in the movie
is about halfway the same as it was in the
comics it's not exactly the same but it's close
originally what happened in the comics is that
thor became unworthy because that version of nick
fury whispered in his ear saying gore was right
in gore the god butcher's whole ethos during that
storyline is that he was killing all the mcu guys
because he felt like the gods didn't care about
their subjects anymore and technically he was not
wrong now some of the gods did care about their
subjects but most of the gods are incredibly
selfish so technically gore was not wrong
so it's one of those situations where thor kind
of believes himself to be unworthy therefore he
becomes unworthy and doesn't qualify for odin's
enchantment anymore and originally the whole idea
is that asgard needed its protector a champion
so the hammer just found the next most likely
candidate now in the mcu remember our version of
mcu thor is still worthy he still has stormbreaker
so they had to come up with a completely different
reason why jane foster becomes a version of thor
and wields a version of mjolnir so it seems like
what they're explaining is that when gore the god
butcher attacks new asgard for the first time our
mcu thor isn't around because he's off with the
guardians of the galaxy and asgard still needs its
champion as protector and for some reason valkyrie
doesn't qualify for that our mcu jane foster
is just in close proximity to the pieces of the
original mjolnir and what they've done since the
events of thor ragnarok is the asgardians created
this shrine around the area where odin died on the
cliff face and you can see right behind it where
hella broke mjolnir they basically just put the
pieces of it on this shrine here too and it sounds
like jane foster just touches it and that's enough
to activate odin's original enchantment and the
enchantment red whosoever holds this hammer if he
be worthy shall possess the power of thor and it
sounds like her touching it activating the hammer
is enough to reform the hammer and give her her
armor so even though thor is a legit god in the
mcu and he's got his powers from odin biologically
odin's enchantment is sort of like a magic copy
paste workaround that gives some of those powers
to jane foster thor and eventually what seems
like happens the real thor winds up showing up and
seeing what happens and sees this other version of
female thor not completely understanding who it is
right away but i think because on stage they
revealed exactly what they were doing like oh
we're gonna make jane foster this female version
of thor i think that our mcu thor will find out
pretty quickly in the movie who it is like i said
the moonite series that i'm doing videos for right
now is sort of giving us the tutorial in how legit
gods in the mcu work and how they're different
from cosmic beings khonshu and omit are just from
one pantheon of gods thor odin and hella are from
the other asgardian pantheon of gods there are
many many other pantheons from each different
culture in the universe so gor the god pitcher
is going to wind up killing a bunch of mcu gods
supposedly boss the panther goddess where the
panther tribe black panther gets all of his
powers from will appear in the movie they
might also wind up using that for a twist
during black panther too because if something
bad were to happen to boss the panther goddess
theoretically black panther would lose all of his
crazy powers now in the comics it is possible for
black panther to forge an alliance with another
mcu god and get the same type of powers but it
winds up being a completely different god the
different tribes of wakanda all worship different
gods the panther tribe is just the current ruling
tribe right now really good example of that is
zumbaku he's from the ape tribe they worship the
ape god but for those of you asking where the thor
love and thunder trailer has been why haven't
they released it yet is basically because they
want to give you the tutorial on mcu gods during
the moon knight series before they give you the
crash course during thor love and thunder also we
have not gotten doctor strange 2 yet we've seen a
couple of those trailers but the movie hasn't come
out yet they've been waiting till they get closer
to that movie actually coming out to release
the thor trailer so if we'd originally saw
doctor strange in march like they had planned on
we would have already seen the thor trailer by now
it'll be fun to see how thor tries to top all the
crazy x-men multiverse cameos in doctor strange 2
like which marvel movie this year is
going to be the biggest one mild shock
my bet is on doctor strange 2 but let me know
in the comments which marvel movie do you think
will earn the most money this year i will post
a full thor love and thunder trailer video as
soon as they release it probably later this
month everyone click here for my moon knight
episode 3 trailer video and click here for my
full moon knight episode 2 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!